[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the Ramsay show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships I am Ramsey personality
Rachel Cruz co-hosting this hour with
the wonderful Jade warshaw and my
co-host chair right there and we are
taking your calls it's a free call
anywhere in the country at 88 25 5225
and again talking about your life and
your money so give us a call so first up
this hour we have Laura in Toronto
Canada hey Laura welcome to the show hi
thank you so much I'm so excited to be
able to talk to you guys today thank you
for having me on yeah absolutely thanks
for calling how can we help so I've been
listening to your show Daily for the
last few months and I read Total Money
Makeover and now I need some advice so
we've always been fairly responsible and
Frugal with our money um but since
listening to you guys recently I've
wanted to start doing more so I've been
selling off a lot of things that we
don't need or use anymore kind of like
how everybody suggests to sell
everything until the kids think they're
next um my three-year-old and my
5-year-old are now starting to notice
and have started asking more questions
about money and what I'm saving for and
where it's going so my question is do
you have any advice on how to talk to
kids about money and at what age and is
there a way to teach them to respect it
without causing any kind of anxiety I
know my girls are still little but I
don't want to burden them with adult
things like debt and mortgages but I
want to try and start them off right
yeah we don't want to talk about like
government shutdown and stuff with our
5-year-old yeah yeah yeah um no I think
it's a great question Laura and I think
even your intentionality behind it early
on um is huge and then I would say too I
give you props that your kids are
picking up on what you're doing because
we always say if you're a parent you
know more is caught than taught like
your kids are watching so much of what
you're the choices you're making in life
and even your tions around it right they
they pick up so much and so um the fact
that they're seeing change in you Laura
I think is amazing because that means
you're changing right you're doing
something different when it comes to
your money and they're seeing that so
Props to you in that regard uh but yeah
I mean I would keep it very age
appropriate I think we do find families
that are in a season of sacrifice to
make a financial goal like getting out
of debt or having money saved uh to
bring the kids along in that and make it
a family themed idea right that like as
a family we are choosing to do this and
it's not just Mom and Dad in isolation
doing it and so talking yeah so talking
to them and I think again age
appropriately and just saying yeah you
know Mom and Dad we don't want money to
be a stress point in our life so for us
you know whether it's you're getting out
of debt so we don't so we actually when
Mom and Dad make money from work we get
to keep it and decide what we want to do
with it instead of sending it you know
you can even talk to them about payments
and like what that looks like yeah what
de is and so yeah it's again very age
appropriate but starting those
conversations uh I think is is key yeah
Laura I talked since they're so oh sorry
go ahead Jade I was gonna say I you know
my my kids they see this show and they
see us talking about money and debt all
day and my son has started asking like
what is debt and so we've talked to him
about it I mean we've explained that
when you borrow money you have to give
it back and here's what that looks like
and even um as simple as sometimes I'll
go if I buy something and he just thinks
you know you can go to Target and pick
whatever you want off the shelf and I'm
like no when Mama leaves every day I'm
going to earn money and then when we
earn that money we get to decide how to
spend it so there's part of it that just
introducing them to the idea that you go
and you work and then this is what you
get for your time and it's not unlimited
right and I think that's been a big one
and then two just um the choices in your
language right because Dr John and I
were talking about this the other day
your kids remember things mentally but
their body also remembers how things
felt and so when you're going through a
season of getting out of debt if you
guys are feeling anxiety and stress and
oh we got to do this and we got to do it
like this and we got to do it now I
would challenge you to make the feeling
like oh this is so good for us we're
sacrificing we're going to have freedom
we're going to have choices and make it
an exciting thing a thing that feels
like liberating empowering and then
their bodies are going to remember that
feeling oh man when Mom and Dad took
control of their life I mean I've never
seen them more confident so I think
there's a lot that can be done with the
mood that you're creating um in the
house surrounding getting out of debt
and that sort of thing yeah that's good
uh I know I'm reading I'm reading a book
right now uh Goff wrote and it's
all about uh anxiety and kids and she
talks about that as a parent if you have
anxiety your kids are are seven times
more likely for that so just that I
think that's key are the environment you
creates is it is it's huge it impacts
your kids and then the other thing Laura
I would also say with your kids so that
that everything we just kind of spoke on
was the perspective of you know you as
the parent reacting to your money
situation to your kids but let your kids
feel and experience money on their own
and so having them even at their age you
know they can do a couple of chores here
and there ab and pay them and teaching
them especially you're older when you're
5-year-old you know give save and spend
it's like these three basic buckets of
money but it's buckets that as adults
that's basically what we can do with
money we can give it we can save it and
spend it and we want do all three and so
you kind of start letting them
experience the emotion and the principal
uh H you know habit building ideas
around money themselves even at a young
age so Laura if you hang on the line
Austin's going to pick up and I want to
give you financial piece Junior because
that's our set of teaching young kids
how to handle money and smart money
smart kids it's the first book I wrote
uh with my dad I was a New York Times
bestseller because it was it's all about
the perspective from the child of
growing up in a home where money is
talked about and it's in a perspective
that is healthy and obviously dad was
the parent in that and what they did so
um I'm going to give you those Laura
because I think this is this is the part
of this show that we talk about changing
your family tree absolutely because
there's a
generational uh Habit that is built and
what your kids see and what they
experience and what they believe about
money is passed down to them and you can
do it well uh and intentional like you
are or sometimes it's just accidental
and your kids get what they get right
and and so I think the intentional
routes is really it's important because
money is such a stressful part of life
and when your kids can see that healthy
perspective it's big so thanks Laura for
the call we appreciate it so Jade what's
been the biggest stuff because your kids
are how old two uh three and five so so
you have exactly their age yeah exactly
and my oldest he's just at the point
where it's like oh okay so he does
chores and he gets you know a little bit
of money for his chores but still going
into the story he doesn't understand
like this only Buys so much so we're
constantly explaining like you only have
so much and if you want more you have to
work more and the more you work the more
money you have and you can buy things
that are more expensive so we're kind of
in that phase right now um my youngest
you know she's she's she's not there yet
yeah yeah yeah no no she's not there yet
but yeah yeah I know and it's it's so
funny too to watch your kids and and I
have a 8-year-old and a six-year-old and
for sure there are personalities when
comes to it where I'm like I know which
way you're going to be bent um and I
just announced today actually I'm I have
a kids book coming out in November it's
called I'm glad for what I have and it's
dedicated to my middle daughter because
it it's all about contentment and it's
for younger kids but it's um learning
that contentment piece is huge that it's
okay to have nice stuff yeah but we
don't want our nice stuff to have us and
our kids think that the Amazon delivery
guy is like part of the family right so
I'm like they can get in come whenever
he wants yeah they get in this rhythm of
like what what stuff is today czy is our
kids don't even see money they don't see
cash anymore they don't see even debit
cards or credits it's on your phone
you're buying online so making that
connection for our kids in a real life
scenario is so is so key so key so
thanks again Lura for the call and we'll
be
[Music]
back
hey guys I've told you before about
Christian Healthcare Ministries a health
cost sharing Ministry but listen to
Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concerns about entrepreneurship
and motherhood was figuring out how to
take care of our health expenses but we
have found a solution that works for us
in an incredible way way she loves that
with chm she can help other families who
need it and receive help back when her
own family has an eligible medical event
chm has been a godsend for Jenna that's
her chm story and it could be yours
learn more and join at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsy show I am
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour with
Ramsey personality Jade warshaw and if
you guys enjoy the show it's so helpful
if you share the show subscribe to the
show leave a review all of those things
really help in the algorithm of the
world of podcast and YouTube and all of
it uh because we want the show in front
of as many people as possible because we
want to be able to help them when it
comes to their life and their money so
it's always helpful when you guys do
that we know you do it because we see uh
the response and the numbers and all of
it so we're so grateful for that and
again trying to get trying to get this
country under control Jade I know that's
right one show at a time show at a time
one episode at a time all right up next
we have philli in Birmingham hey Phillip
welcome to the
show hey guys thanks for having me on
absolutely how can we
help so I got maybe more of a two-part
question um I'll start with the with the
first part so I've been listening pretty
intently for the past week uh I did
financial piece when me and my wife
first got married six years ago um and
haven't really followed it as close
probably should have uh we currently
have $133,000 in unhealthy debt that we
own on a car and we have 135 wait wait
wait wait wait wait when you say
unhealthy debt what do you mean by that
and tell me what the healthy debt
is uh the only reason I say that is I'm
I'm just putting my mind in the right
perspective that I want to get rid of
all all of our dead Okay so there so you
do know there's not really like healthy
debt per se
absolutely but plenty of people would
say it's completely necessary to get a
car yes and that that's fine and I I
don't want to I don't want to go with a
grain on that okay good so I'm trying to
allow myself emotionally to catch up to
uh lifestyle changes that me and wife
are stared make over the past like few
weeks and the first start is just
mentally saying okay we're gonna have
we're gonna have a little bit of a a
verbal battle with what the world
typically tells people her and me
changing your
language J I like it you're not getting
anything past Jade Philip so watch out
$13,000 in debt um which is unhealthy as
it all is so what else you got correct
um and then and then our mortgage which
we owe 135k we got that three years ago
um thankfully before things got really
crazy but still we owe 135k on that um
aside from that we have we have zero
debt zero medical bills zero student
loans so we're okay on that side
but we still want to get ahe the curb
and that's the first part of just saying
hey this is this is everything we have
going on right now and the second part
of my question was I I do want to get
rid of the debt we have in our car but I
also haven't invested nearly as much
into our retirement as I want to I
currently invest into a Roth IRA and um
my question was should I keep hitting
like should I maximize as much much I
can to my Roth IRA and still try to pay
extra on the car or should I put that on
hold knock out the car first and then
hit uh my rothar and mutual funds Heavy
after that yeah um I see the benefit of
both sides I just I don't want to I'm
already I'm I'm be 31 yeah I think
you're I think you're freaking out and I
I think you're freaking out and I don't
think you need to freak out as as bad as
you are I like that you're on top of
this I like that you're looking at um
the future and you're going all right
what do I need to do to make sure that
we're set up in the best possible way um
but you know you're you're not new to
our teaching so you know we walk through
a series of baby steps and so what do
you think that I'm going to
say uh we need to get rid of our our car
loan ding ding ding yeah and do you know
why though the do you know kind of the
principle behind that sure so what is it
you're te you're you're teach you're the
teacher right now because I think you
know
this uh I do it just helps having a
third party who's unbiased kind
of I'm not unbiased I'm not unbiased but
so Philip I think I think the I think
what you can get in your head because
you sounds we always say there's like
either the nerd or the free spirit are
you probably the nerd I'm going to
assume uh a little bit yeah a little bit
okay yeah yeah I thought I was right uh
you know you're running numbers and
calculations and all of this and you're
seeing Oh my gosh you know my WTH and my
retirement all of it and and I
understand that I really really do and
again
what you said at the beginning of the
call is we're going against the grain
and what the grain would say is yeah go
ahead you fund retirement you do uh that
you try to you know keep up with your
credit card balance and your you know
you can pay a little bit on your car
some on your H you know you just spread
everything around and you kind of just
get mediocre right mediocrity is what
the result ends up being uh because
there's not intentional focus on one
thing and so the great thing for you
Phillip is that you're 31 and so
retirement if you hold off a few years
because how much do you guys make a year
how much do you and your wife
make U anywhere between 55 and 60k okay
yeah so you guys will have yeah some
time to pay off this car and maybe it's
you know maybe it's uh you take an extra
job you guys are cutting stuff you're
selling stuff uh you do all of that you
know maybe it's a maybe it's an 18mon
turnaround right 12 months it's a year
okay that's not going to be detrimental
to your retirement it's really not I
mean overall because you're going to be
able to invest more money if you think
about just even if you took that car
payment and added that to your WTH on
top of what you would have done right
like I mean it just it starts to
compound and that's the great thing is
that you're going to catch up and and
here's the deal too Philip if you were
61 Our advice would be the same
regardless and so so where you are is in
a great spot you are in a you're in a
healthy spot you see the problem attack
that car get it out of here and then
that's going to free you guys up to use
some s have some Savings in an emergency
fund do you all have any money saved
right now
uh just our emergency fund uh we had
some medical bills we had a daughter
this year and I was paying the taxes
from R over my 4on can to a Roth IR okay
and um after after my wife being I'm
maternity leave which we planed to head
for that but it kind of puts us back to
just having an emergency fund but we
have around $3,000 in savings right now
okay um that's that's all we have at the
moment okay that's great um and I would
be curious you don't need to sell the
car because I think you guys can pay
this off but even if you wanted to run
the numbers for fun Philip I mean
there's some people that call the show
and they're like I want out of debt
tomorrow like I like get me out and they
would take a hit on the car take a
smaller loan you know get a be I mean
they'll go through that process you
don't need to the math is is on your
side in that in that regard yeah um
you're not in that urgent of a state but
I would say yeah run some numbers while
y'all are kind of going against the
grain just keep pushing at it yeah I
think you'd be surprised how quickly
that you'll pay off this 13k um if you
get intense I think it'll go by way
faster than you
thought that's encouraging yeah yep
absolutely well thanks for calling
Phillip I appreciate and good luck to
you guys and congrats on the on the new
addition most definitely the new baby
yeah this is I feel like one of the
things that is a it's kind of a myth in
the personal finance space is that you
can do 18 things at once yeah and the
secret is if there is a secret is
especially early on when you're getting
out of debt and you're wanting to save a
chunk of money in an emergency fund when
you are focused and you point everything
at one thing and you spend time on it
even if it takes a year if it takes 18
months 24 months the progress you see in
that is where the idea that personal
finan is 80% Behavior it's only 20% head
knowledge comes into play like when you
start to win and you start to see
progress not like teeny teeny things
here and there and random things like
big steps big progress in one area like
paying off debt it it's it's motivating
well yeah because if if you don't Focus
right let's say you've got $500 extra
dollars at the end of the month and
you're like I'm going to start paying
off debt and each debt gets $50 like you
never see the needle move and before you
know you're like this is not working and
you just lose your motivation and you go
back to your old habits but when you
suddenly take that $500 and you throw it
at a credit card bill that's 2,000 and
you're done Y in four months you're like
wait a second like I can keep going I
can do this forever and so there's
definitely something to be said for
Focus intensity turning it you know
turning the light into a laser beam and
you're burning through uh that debt so I
mean that's that's the way to do it
that's the way that works yep absolutely
absolutely and then again the the idea
that people get caught up just like he
did Philip it's such a that's such a
normal mindset of freaking out about
retirement because we do see these
charts of compound interest that if you
started at 18 you know what you what you
would be all of it which is all great
and it's true yeah time is your friend
but yes but getting things in order and
having a peaceful Foundation under you
financially before you start going and
looking far in the future it's it
changes everything it changes it changes
the emotion around money it really does
so thanks again Philip for the call this
is the ramsy
[Music]
show
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from lines drapes and
shutters to motorized Shades they make
it easy and affordable to upgrade your
entire home and their team is ready to
help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online reta Tor of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 40% off everything sitewide
go to blinds.com for more
[Music]
information
welcome back to the Ramsay show so Jade
I'm so excited I think it's in two
weekends from now yes October 19th
through the 21st our money and marriage
event is happening here at the Ramy
event center right up the hill if you're
here uh and it's going to be a multi-day
event over the weekend Dr John Zone and
I are kind of heading it up and we're
really diving into these topics of money
and marriage for a full weekend and Jade
you're going to be here too I am I'm so
excited but we were just talking about
how this is very different than some of
the other events that we've done in a
very good way yes so yeah it's a lot of
um really I think like a just a point of
connection we want to have uh with the
audience because it's couples that are
going to be there and again it's these
two subjects that can be really
difficult to talk about at times and so
we it's just it's it's going to be very
casual yes it's going to be really fun
we want to give you the tools to be able
to cast a vision maybe challenge you in
some areas uh to be able to walk away
but there's um some fun guests John and
I uh we doing a panel actually my
husband Winston's gonna be there and
John's wife Sheila which this is a big
deal this this never happens the spouses
never end up coming but we ROP them and
Jade you're going to be there for your
session with Sam Sam's gonna be there
too yeah your husband so yeah it's going
to be a hangout we have evening things
pln for you guys so it's going to be
really fun so our VIP and platinum
tickets are already sold out so there's
a few more just general emission so if
you want to go go to Ramsey
solutions.com
events it's
$799 a couple and yes we want you out of
debt of course we want you on baby steps
four five or six but I'm saying for two
people at $7.99 yeah for two yep so
again multi-day event and it's going to
be really fun here in Nashville so get
some time away from the kids get away
from your normal life come hang out in
Nashville with us money and marriage
October 19th through the 21st again go
to Ramsey solutions.com
events uh to join us love it all right
up next we have Sean in Louisville hey
Shan welcome to the
show hi Jade hi Rachel thank you so much
for taking my call absolutely how can we
help well um so my wife and I are on
baby steps for five six and we found out
that uh we are going to have our second
child um some around June
congratulations thank you so so my my
question is what your all thoughts are
on um
pausing um pausing four five and six to
uh to save up for for the
baby okay so you guys I'm just
clarifying you have no debt how much
savings do you have in your emergency
fund uh 11 or 12,000 okay that's great
how much how much do you need for the
baby like what's your deductible going
to
be um excuse me um it uh I've looked
through so many numbers actually trying
to figure out what plan we're going on
next year um so like out of pocket I
think would be like 7,000 okay
um and you're investing 15% right
now right I would probably pause the
other two I would keep investing I
wouldn't stop investing I think still
investing your 15% but if you guys want
to kind of like pull back from paying
off the you know if you're putting ex sh
towards the house or something and you
want to pull back and save up what
that's going to be uh I think that's
that's a good rule of thumb because we
always do tell people to pause the debt
snowball if you're getting out of debt
uh to pause that and pile up cash if
you're expecting a baby uh but besides
that seaa I mean I would I wouldn't
retirement how much you guys make a
year uh 70k okay have you run out the
numbers um what that would look like
without pausing and where how much are
you able to save by June if you if you
weren't
pausing so if
we just stopped five and six um we're
able to save up like 450 a month but it
doesn't uh it still doesn't quite get us
to the to that 7,000 Mark I think that's
where the um where the concern
is what does it get you
to do the mouth real quick it's I want
to say like I want to say like
5,000
maybe what I would do um I honestly I'll
be honest I wouldn't pause
retirement for that I would and then as
the bills come in I'd pay the bills as
they come in
and you might be surprised because I'm
thinking I'm trying to think back
through this Rachel of when I had babies
and some of the stuff came in right away
some of it I prepaid and most of it's at
the end most at the end and they start
rolling in but it's not like it's not
like in one day you have to write a
check for $7,000 right so MH I'd
probably just cash flow it cash flow the
bills as they come in and Sean if you
guys get to the get to the end of it and
you need $1,000 from your emergency
funds then it's not the end of the world
yeah grab the th000 you have saved there
keep funding retirement put your $ th000
you know back into the emergency fund
refill it and you guys just keep going
but I I would hate for you to
lose um Steam on that now if you were
telling me that you
needed
$177,000 or something yeah then we can
talk about it but the fact that you guys
are so close to be able to cash flow it
and the bigger thing too here is is I
wouldn't want to for me it's a habit
forming thing I wouldn't want to build
the habit of when we need to do
something we stop retirement does that
make sense even though this is very
important I think there's something to
be said for that resourcefulness okay
how can we make this work because going
forward there are going to be things
that you need to do not just want to do
but need to do that are going to be you
know very expensive and I don't want to
build the thought of well we could pause
retirement for a little while to make it
happen does that make sense that's kind
of where my mind is going on
and if it were If This Were the
conversation going on in my house with
Sam that's the that's the argument that
I would bring up I'd be like well Sam
you know I think that we can do this
without building that habit so yep
absolutely so y we'd cash flow it dip
into the emergency fund at the end if
you need to uh but like Jade said I
think you'll be surprised I think you
guys will be able to get through this so
thanks for the call up next we have
Blake in Salt Lake City Utah hey Blake
welcome to the show hey thanks so much
for having me absolutely how can we
help so I am 23 years old I'm a flooring
contractor married with a 2-year-old son
and we have racked up about 30 well we
racked up $33,000 worth of debt and I've
paid about 3,000 of it off um we're
looking at
like looking at my note here $2,200 left
in credit cards um $122,000 on a truck
for my job and
$117,000 on a car for my wife and I want
to plan go to school here in the next
two or three years for an associates
degree in uh mechatronic
engineering and I just want to know how
I can best tackle this debt and actually
start saving and putting stuff away yeah
so I can cash flow that school I don't
want to go into debt for an associates
degree and I love that kind of just lost
yeah no totally uh how much are you
making right now um I make about 70,000
a year gross that's great what about
your
wife um she is not working she is uh
just at home with our our boy okay good
um so my first thought is there's always
the the idea that you've got to increase
your income the faster you want to pay
off the debt obviously the more income
coming in is going to be helpful for
that so my mind immediately goes to is
there anything that you can do to
increase your income and is there
anything that your wife can do to get
some income coming in cuz when it comes
to paying off debt ,000 extra dollars a
month does a world of difference $2,000
extra a month does a world of difference
so that's my first question to you I
know she's staying home uh with a young
one but is there something that she
could do um while she's at
home um she's a before um we had our son
she actually got certified as a child
birth Dua uhuh um so that she did that
for a while first married and you know
every once in a while she's brought in
you know a couple thousand bucks here
and there she just is so anxious about
like spending time away from her from
our boy just because she didn't have a
dad growing up
and I totally yeah I hear that and I
would say for a season not a pattern
over life but for a season maybe that's
something you guys look into and then
also Blake she you guys have almost
$30,000 in car debt oh yeah I would look
at the $177,000 car and see how much
it's worth if you guys could sell that I
mean that that knocks down your debt
significantly even if you're upside down
yeah yeah taking smaller loan and then I
mean that gets you guys far ahead so
Blake honestly for me I would look I
would look at the cars to get a jump
start on that so thanks for the
[Music]
call hey if you're in over your head
with student loans and tired of getting
calls from collection agencies if
private student loan debt is taking away
your financial piece and you don't see
any way out you need why refi they're
not a debt settlement company and
they're not connected to a bank y refi
refinances defaulted private student
loans that other places won't touch and
gives you a custom loan built for you
based on your ability to pay so when you
refinance your private student loan debt
with Y refi you'll have a payment you
can afford with a low fixed interest
rate you couldn't get anywhere else to
help you stick to your budget and work
the debt snowball and you can save
thousands of dollars to learn more about
this custom refinancing option and a
lumps some payoff option you could
qualify for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey welcome back to the ramsy show I
am Rachel Cruz hosting this hour with
Ramsey personal
warshaw we're taking your calls it's a
free call anywhere in the country at
5225 up next we have Jay in
Orlando hey Jay welcome to the show hey
girls how you guys doing doing well how
are you awesome awesome I just uh jump
right into my question here yes um I've
got a pay for house it's worth about
300,000 uh but we have about
150,000 in uh student loans and car or
car debt so I'm wondering is it wise to
sell that home pay off every single
penny of debt uh rent for maybe a year
or two and then um and then uh buy
another home down the road what's your
income I'm working right now myself my
wife is finishing uh PTA School uh
she'll be starting in probably April or
May so right now we're at about 65 ,000
a year and what will she be making when
she
starts uh she'll be probably around the
same 65 70 somewhere in that range okay
so you've got the student loans and can
you break down the student loans versus
the
cars yeah we've got about 110 in student
loans okay and then uh about 30 for the
car and the rest in credit cards and a
stupid refrigerator oh gosh so about
10,000 yes okay uh 20,000 um so this car
what you owe 30,000 on it what's it
worth uh we're we're upside down
probably about seven Grand so it's
probably worth about 22 or 23 right now
is that private
sale private sale yes well if it were me
I'd probably be trying to get out of it
um I'd probably take the $7,000 hit and
to to owe less um to knock this debt
down significantly
um I'll be honest with
you I wouldn't sell the house I just
wouldn't it's such an amazing asset it's
going up in value if you were to get out
of it now my guess is your interest rate
now is far better than it would be in
the next year or so if you were to save
up and try to buy it's like I almost
feel like you'd be going backwards to
try to go forward when right now
literally you can just go
forward yeah and Jade and your wife when
is she going to start work when did you
say she
graduates uh she graduates in December
she's taking her board in April so
she'll probably uh be working like the
end of April early May next year okay
okay so you still you guys have about
six months to that so I mean honestly
your life changes dramatically Jay once
she starts working so you guys I mean
it'll take you guys you know a few years
to do this but I would rather spend a
few years getting out of this Consumer
Debt than taking a hit on an asset like
a home like I just don't think um
selling it and here's another thing Jay
that I always caution people not that
it's always and you can go do what you
want and some people they want to sell
their house they want out of debt they
want to do it but but here's the problem
too when you get a lump sum of money
this is even true with an inheritance or
you know if you had an insurance claim
and you you know got some cash a big
sweep of just getting some cash just to
clear out the debt yes that's great
because we want you debt-free but also
there is something about Behavior change
that is so crucial and behavior change
is caused when you feel a level of pain
you feel a level of sacrifice and you
actually win like when you go through
that Journey that's what changes you Jay
and so not that you know if you get a
bunch of money we want you to pay it off
right I'm not saying not to do it but
also in the same time it doesn't always
change Jay it doesn't always change you
it doesn't change your wife when you
just can you know just do this full
sweep so you know Rachel I think I am
going to say not to do it not to sell
the house no we D yeah I think we're
gonna like yeah don't sell the house
make yourself go through this process
you guys need to do it and and you're
going to get a jump start on this
process in six months like these next
six months you're going to feel it
Christmas J is not going to look like
Christmas last year like you're going to
be cutting back on things and that's
okay for a season and then when your
wife starts working that's going to be
gasoline on this and like Jade said and
if you if you sell the car you know then
that brings you guys back down to what
120 125 I mean you know you're just
starting to knock this stuff out and so
and you've got okay so they've got the
20 the 20,000 in credit cards and
refrigerator loans that to me like
that's that's the kind of debt that
keeps you motiv at because it's like
$2,000 here and a th000 like those are
the quick wins that you start to go oh
oh yeah we can do this so the way I'll
just say the way your debt is set up
it's the kind that's like yes like we
can really see this traction we can see
the movement forward so yeah do not sell
that house walk through it yep
absolutely does that help
Jay yes that absolutely helps thank you
so much I appreciate that absolutely and
remember always you guys and those of
you listening or watching that you know
the the Deep you sacrifice and the
deeper you say we're not going on a
summer trip next summer we're not doing
Christmas like we like you just have a
season where things are cut back and
it's not forever it's not forever it's
for a season to get this progress to get
this debt paid off and then Jay you guys
are s what's crazy to me is I'm like you
know after this journey of maybe what
two years three years doing this yeah
you guys are going to be sitting in a
paid for home with M you know you guys
are going to be making I mean oh my gosh
oh yeah a lot yeah yeah 1:30 I mean like
it's it it it's powerful to know what
your income is going to be able to do
when all this debt is cleaned up so the
future is there we see it we see not to
mention so many people Rachel right now
are like this housing market is so hard
with interest rates and everything it's
so hard to save enough down payment I'm
like if you can avoid that because you
already have property I would not want
to jump into that if I didn't have to
nope nope not at all all right Jay
thanks for the call up next we got Jen
in Sacramento hey Jen welcome to the
show
hi Rachel and Jay thank you so much for
taking my call absolutely how can we
help yes so um I'm wondering if I should
change jobs uh while pregnant or stay at
my current job which is far away okay um
my husband and I are currently on baby
step number two and we just found out
that we're expecting our second child
next June oh
congratulations thank you yeah so we
both work a hybrid schedule we're two
and a half hours away and it pays more
um stays with his family two nights out
of the week just to stay close to work
and I go in twice a week which is a 5our
commute each day we almost a year yeah
we've been doing this for almost a year
now and so now that we're expecting our
second child this is just kind of on my
mind what are you guys earning at this
job to make it worth it or is it not
worth it it is worth it so he works
actually two jobs he works at a hospital
and admin and he also got a side hustle
as a adun professor uhhuh um my job I've
been getting a raise since I started but
it doesn't pay as I mean it pays pretty
decent what is
it I'm in a an administrative
coordinator yeah but what are you guys
earning healthare oh so our total take
home income a month is
15,200 okay um and we have $100,000 in
stud of
loans um a car loan balance of
7900 we have a mortgage with 377k left
um and then we also have a loan for a
solar panel which is about
okay so I don't know if I I want to work
part-time but that would like cut into
like our goal of like trying to pay off
debt um and also work like closer
considering like a change in career like
maybe a preschool teacher but I don't
know I definitely think that the 2 and 1
half hours is not sustainable like you
can't continue to do that especially
with the kids coming um that being said
I do think you need to find a happy
median because going from 15,000 a month
when you have this debt down to
preschool teacher sell you know what I
mean that's a big jump down so I think
that there's got to be a way that you
can meet in the middle um in order to
make this happen um and kind of do it
gradually to where you're still having a
nice shovel to pay off this debt because
the hard thing to walk away from is such
a high income when you do have that debt
and with that income you could knock it
yeah 100 Grand in student loans right I
mean and that's I'm sure for was it for
you and your
husband yeah majority of it's mine
yeah and okay you know like don't get me
wrong you're pregnant there's some
things that go into that obviously once
you have a baby but I try to ride this
out until as long as you can until
you've got to make that switch because
when the baby's born for sure you're
going to have to make that switch and
you should start preparing now yeah and
if you're 6 months pregnant and you
don't want to be sitting in a car for 5
hours EX that's very understandable Jen
so so looking at yeah how how long you
can do that and when you switch jobs
though insurance is Big so you want to
make sure your insurance is covered
because with the pregnancy and
everything make sure you don't miss that
because it may be worth it just stay in
just for the insurance to make sure you
and baby are good so make sure to cover
that J but yeah this is the hard thing
with debt you have it and it's like oh
my gosh we have to pay this off and some
sacrifices have to be made so congrats
though on the new baby Jin uh and thanks
for the call all right that puts the
sour in the book thank you Jay for being
a great co-host thanks to all the guys
in the booth for helping us out this is
the Ramsey
Show hey it's Rachel Cruz if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the ramsy way just go to ramsy
solutions.com today to sign up for our
newsletter again that's ramsy
solutions.com to sign up for our Weekly
Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships I am Ramsey personality
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour with the
wonderful and the fabulous Ramsey
personality Jade warshaw we are here to
answer your calls America and it is a
free call anywhere in the country at
5225 so make sure uh yeah give us a call
let us know what's your what your
thinking what your questions are and
we'd love to walk through your
situations with you that's what we're
here for so up first we have Taylor in
Nashville here in our home City
Nashville Taylor welcome to the show
hi thank you for having me absolutely
how can we
help um so well I just actually am
calling for my boyfriend um
unfortunately he had gotten caught up
into some things that had landed him in
jail for about two years unexpectedly oh
okay um he is home now um and during
that time his mother was able to keep
his car payment and his mortgage paid um
but of course wasn't able to also take
care of his like personal loan debt and
credit card debt of course you know he's
very thankful that she was even able to
do that sure um and now that he you know
he is home he is on like a you know
probation parole type thing um where
really selling his house is not an
option um even though he does have quite
a bit of equity because then he would be
homeless and being on supervision you
have to have an address of course right
um and his credit score is you know in
like upper mid 400s right now just
because all of that credit card debt and
personal loan debt is now in collections
and has been for you know about a year
and a half now and how much debt is it
total um in collections total it's about
30,000 uhhuh and then he owes about 133
on his house uhuh 133,000 on his house
and his car he owes about what it's
worth which is about
13,000 and is he working is has he been
able to find any work coming out of jail
yes um we were he's making about $15 an
hour right now I have gotten him you
know like an every dollar budget kind of
laid out so as far as like that goes you
know obviously he's slowly trying to
work up that baby step one yeah um but
just having all of it in collections
it's just hard to find really any
information on you know like if that
settlement might be an or bankruptcy or
if we should you know contact them
directly it's just really hard to kind
of find any advice really yeah is it
mostly credit cards in the collections
or personal loans or what um credit
cards and then there is one personal
loan okay how much is the credit cards
credit cards
is about 20,000 okay and are those
separate cards how
many um about three or four and then I
think there's like yeah about three or
four and are those all from different
banks and yeah everything okay if it
were me I would start with those like
once he's got the Thousand saved because
he really does need that I'd start with
the collections first obviously and I
would like let's just say he's got one
credit card in collections that's $2,000
I'd stack up $600 or $700 and I'd say
this is what I have can we make a deal
and they're going to make it if it's in
collections they're going to make a deal
with you the key there is making sure
you get every deal in writing before you
pay them the money right and you're
you're not giving them access to your
account you're saying okay I'll write
you a check or I'll do it online
whatever that is um and you're keeping
that record forever and I would
literally go down the list of those
credit cards and I'd settle them for as
low as I possibly could make sure you
have the cash ready because you know you
can't just call and say what would
happen if I did this they're going to be
like no we want your money but if you
say look I and honestly in this case I'd
shoot straight I'd be like look I just
got out of prison this is what I have I
got $500 and if you don't take this
you're not getting anything from me so
take it or leave it and Taylor usually
with these collection situations they're
passed and then they're sold to another
collection agency and then another I
mean this could be the third time handed
down you know one of these credit card
debts so just just know the the the
system that you're working under and
it's and the you know people aren't in
these jobs forever they're sitting in a
cube somewhere I mean like it's just
it's just a it's just a nasty industry
it really is and so uh getting yes
someone and I think the key here is what
you're saying is you need to pull up his
credit reports you need guys need to
find exactly that okay good where the
debt is what it is and then try to find
that yes Whoever has that um that bill
and collections calling the collections
agency and Jade is exactly right
majority of the time they will settle
with you and if you have that cash say I
can send this to you now and they may
want to negotiate a little bit so kind
of play the game but if but when they
say okay fine we'll take the
$721 say okay great I need you to mail
me um you know with a letter like give
me an official letter of agreement
and once I receive that I will I will
send the money and so you guys just kind
of work work that through and then for
his car um I don't know I feel like this
is the sell the car show so far today
but honestly I'm like it's $133,000 and
um and I know he needs a car for work so
if the payments are not overwhelming him
but where he's at again you want these
debts knocked out but simultaneously if
there was any other way do you know what
the payment is uh 444 W who W that is
kind of high yes um whenever he got it
he had just started building his credit
so his interest rate was high yeah um
and you know and now we it's unfortunate
because he does have about with the he
bought his house right before the market
kind of went crazy um so if he was to
refinance you know he'd have about 100K
in equity in his house um so it is kind
of unfortunate it's just hard to you
know he can't be homeless what is his is
well okay selling his house doesn't make
him homeless because he can rent right
so what is his mortgage payment having
like this felony record um finding
somewhere
tuent um is a real big issue in the area
that he's in I here well what's his
mortgage and are you helping him with
his mortgage because $15 an hour not his
boyfriend or his mom lives with him
currently because she just um had to
move out of her house or her apartment
so she's living with him helping him but
the mortgage is about 1100 a month yeah
that's okay um
okay
I this is his situation not yours um oh
yeah 100% I'm just trying to I'm a you
know working my own baby step yeah I'm
just trying to advise him the best I can
because um I'll be honest theage and
stuff on it the mortgage and house thing
does scare me making $15 an hour and
having to kind of depend on whoever is
able to live with him at the moment um
that might be a problem for down the
line
um yeah if I were talk yeah we good well
part of me would get out of that because
it's just debt that
he tayl you're nervous that he's not
going to be able to find a place to rent
because of his felony record is that
correct but I feel like you could do the
I feel like if you it's not like to say
that hey sell the house and then look
for a place but maybe you can start
doing the research on the front end and
just keep keep bringing it up
you
know 12 months a manager of an apartment
complex will work with him cuz Jade's
right there's a lot on here um and where
he is you know just in life uh it's just
a lot so Taylor the places that he can
take off that weight so whether it's
selling the car the housing situation is
big and as Jade you know pondering all
that like it's true it's it's a big
piece of this puzzle um but I would
start with that Collections and you guys
work on that and Taylor you're very
supportive very
so thanks for all that you're doing in
his life that's huge this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show hey folks you know that sinking
feeling when you make an offer on a
house you love and then you hear there's
another offer you need the Churchill
Mortgage home buyer Edge super fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus a $5,000 seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to Churchill
mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I am
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour with Jade
warshaw fellow Ramsey personality and
taking your calls so Jade I feel like in
life there's these moments in your life
that you look back and you're like oh
yeah that changed everything right uh I
think about like September 11th and the
way you go through airports changed
everything right so different moments
and so one of those moments in history
for us will forever be Co yes that it
changed everything is what it feels like
and it changed the way that we do life
the way that we shop what we expect the
convenience element suddenly you don't
have to go on target you can just pull
right up and oh man they bring the bags
out to you so some of that's good all
these new features yes uh but but
Americans uh they have not slowed down
when it comes to their online purchases
so whether it's Amazon or door Dash uh
these things are more popular than ever
we got used to things being dropped
right at our door comfy cozy and there
was an interesting article from USA
Today that's right it says prices are up
it says although the pandemic has eased
Americans seem to be spending more than
ever for the convenience of having
groceries meals and household wears
delivered directly to their doors the
average delivery service customer is
spending this is crazy around
$47 a month in 2023 that's up $157 from
2021 my gosh it doubled in two years
that's what help me understand Rachel
because I'm like wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute on the one side all
you hear is inflation interest rates I
can't do anything I can't student loans
and everybody's like their life is
imploding but somehow they're still able
to Door Dash you know that sub sandwich
and I'm like how McDonald's yeah that
that's the funniest thing like
McDonald's some somehow you still are
eating McDonald's in bed that they've
delivered to you even though cost
probably more than your McDonald's meal
oh come on let's talk about that it says
in the lining tree survey 82% of
customers or consumers said they used
OnDemand delivery over the past year by
and large the survey found that
consumers chose delivery out of what
convenience always Comfort which I get
that's okay I want okay so I want to
know from you what you and Sam your
household because I'll tell I I'll go
first here's what we you go first Rachel
before Co I went to the grocery store
all the time yeah and did it y'all
during covid and now after I still have
my instacart subscription and it is the
most convenient wonderful thing it is so
for me it is convenient the grocery
delivery and the best one is it has
Costco so I don't true that and I still
will randomly go into Costco because I'm
like there's still some stuff that I may
miss but to have Costco delivered to to
my door look I I do I pay the extra fee
and I pay the subscription well your
delivery fee technically is taken care
of if you have the subscription and then
I tip on top of that so it is more and
they do kind of mess with the prices I
think so like overall I oh they 100% do
I know I'm spending more I know I am
like instacart tells you but to be a mom
and not have to take three kids in the
grocery store and I come home and like
it's there I don't know and Donna
delivered it and I'm like Donna thank
you you made my day Donna so much better
so that is that that's my it's my guilty
PL it's my it's where I spend Jade I
don't do food delivery I don't do to eat
unless it's like pizza delivery or
something but other than that I don't do
yeah like Pizza Del delivery I don't
feel like that falls into this category
because they've always delivered like
that's always been the thing okay do you
not do your you do I'm going to be
honest um Co didn't make me do the
grocery delivery thing like I enjoy
going to the grocery store it I prefer
not going with my kids but I like to go
I like to browse the aisles what made me
start switching to grocery deliveries I
kind of live out far from the stores
that I like and now I work outside the
home and I didn't do that before and so
those two things so my point is whatever
the convenience is cuz for some people
they got in the comfort level after
covid other people you know they're
their life changed and it's like hey now
this is I'm not going to call it a
necessity but it does make your life
easier yeah for sure but here Honestly
by and large here's the real thing if
you can afford it I'm not mad at you
sure but if you can't afford it like if
you're like yeah door Dash on my credit
card bad idea like that's the worst idea
ever cuz you've got the look if you're
putting door Dash on your credit card
can we just run this number down real
quickly Rachel oh man do an interest
rate of like 22% on the card oh God 22%
added pain and regret then you add your
nachos on top of that then you add the
tip for Chad on top of that and then the
delivery fee the delivery fee yes yeahoo
it better be worth it those nachos
better go down smooth and easy cuz
here's the thing they're going to leave
later they're leaving it's not even
worth it only for a moment you're
literally flushing money down the toilet
that's all I got to say about that for a
moment I know I know okay and then the
other one that hurts me on this two Jade
is Amazon oh gosh Amazon I'm an offender
I'm gonna go ahead and say I'm a I'm a
repeat offender and here's the danger
with Amazon is everything start to feel
like a need where I'm like oh um I'm
trying to think like um my kid's little
power wheels battery died and I just got
one yes yep and you're like we'll just
we'll just Amazon it we'll Amazon it we
and it's this like convenience of life
where before I'm like something stupid
like a light bulb would burn out I'm
like oh next time I go to the store I'll
fix it may be like you know it might be
months a week yeah weeks months later
cuz back in the not with Amazon it's
going to be there in two days and it's
yeah that money is being spent so that
is so true it is it it it does mess I
think with our needs versus wants things
can start to feel like that so again
convenience is not bad and and in my
season of life that is where I would
tend to put some of my margin yeah is
towards the conveniences because it just
makes life easier with three little kids
all the things and people were were
scattered everywhere um but also I will
uh I will Echo what you're saying it
definitely your thinking yeah and if
you're in baby steps especially one
through three you guys it adds up it
adds up and we are sitting here
admitting it adds up and we pay for it
and we do it and we know it we kind of
swallow that pill and go but if you are
looking to cut back these are great
places great places to cut back delete
the amazom app you got to delete the app
thank you Rachel that's what I was
getting to if you're in baby step one or
three you cannot have it on your phone
you got to delete the app door Dash uh
Amazon what's another one definitely I
think about all just all the
subscriptions Uber Eats Uber Eats
instacart instacart in I know sorry
instacart you just can't let it tempt
you it's like because it it adds up
right and I think I would be sick to my
stomach if I went and grocery shopped
with my exact list and went in the store
and just bought versus probably what
what I pay for with the added up I mean
like it is it's a it's a difference so
if you're looking for margin if you're
looking for margin these are great
places to cut but again majority of
Americans are not cutting them the
average Millennial is spending
$575 a month on onDemand delivery well
you know some the past year some of the
deliveries um let's talk about this part
of it Rachel because some of the you can
kind of meet it in the middle right like
you can do like Kroger clicklist and
have them you know the drive up yes
which is actually great because you can
see the total yes and stick within your
budget that that is a good one you know
where you know you order you order them
online and then you go pick it up that
way you're not wandering through you
know you're still saving time on that um
also
now not not if you're in baby step 2 but
if you are ordering food like how easy I
mean again there's cooking dinner at
home which is like oh man and then
there's I'm going to order it and go at
least pick it up can you just put the
key in the ignition can you throw some
sweatpants on and go choosing a delivery
choosing delivery over a trip to the
store triggers delivery fees service
fees and tips together they make up to
36% of food delivery costs wow so it's a
lot you're making bank adding you're
adding a lot and then SE charges on top
of that so wow INF yeah y'all if if
you're looking for margin we are used to
the life of convenience since Co but I
would say Nix it for a season get that
cash back that's right get that margin
back and it is it will give you more
peace of mind because we all need some
peace Jade because we are a we are a
world of a ball of anxiety and our we
are the levels of anxiety are up you
guys sadly the depr question is right
there with it and thankfully we have Dr
John deloney on our team who gives us
truth when it comes to this subject and
he has a brand new book out called
building a non-anxious life it's
available now and you guys listen it is
this is such an important to important
topic to talk about your your mental
health and taking care of who you are as
a person overall don't neglect that like
step into that and learn and if this is
something that you're interested in or
have questions on or feel like oh my
gosh I just need a guide in this whole
area of my life order John's book order
John's book go to Ramy solutions.com
order John's new book building a
non-anxious life you will not regret it
this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
welcome back to the Ramsay show I am
Rachel Cruz hosting with Jade warshaw
and we're here taking your calls it's a
free call anywhere in the country at
8825 5225 here to talk about your life
and your money all right up next we have
Jonathan in Minneapolis hey Jonathan
welcome to the
show hi thank you for taking my call how
are you this afternoon absolutely we are
doing great Jonathan how are you doing
I'm doing very well so um my parents are
a few years away from
retirement uh my wife my parents and I
are thinking about selling both of our
houses and combining living situations
into one larger
house um it would involve temporarily uh
at least
temporarily um increasing the balance of
my mortgage in order to make that
transition and I I've got more details
if you want to go through those but uh
that's quick overview what's the purpose
of combining
homes um so my parents will likely in
the next few years have some medical
situations that would make them not able
to take care of a house long
term um and so basically the house that
we're looking at would be essentially a
basement apartment the size of about
their current
house um and then we would be able to
help take care of them they would be
able to grow up around their grandkids
and everybody's on board with the
situation in
principle um I think
we there's some question on would this
be able to work in the short term versus
trying to make that or trying to wait a
few more years what would
happen whose name would be on the deed
it would be mine or my wife and
I and so can I just can I just jump in
okay I I just feel like Jonathan this
this always
presents um both before a step like this
this situation sounds
always usually better than the outcome
of what occurs you and your wife do you
guys have kids we do two two kids okay
and how old are you
guys uh we're both 32 we have a two kids
under three okay awesome so um very
heroic Noble um the honor and respect
right that you're giving your parents of
hey we want to help take care of you
like all of that is good um but the
Tactical side of combining living
situations you and your wife now your
unit as a family is disrupted right even
though they're downstairs and all of
that like they're the the amount of um
tension and autonomy that will not be
there for your family units is very high
it's very high and so while some
situations work we're in-laws and
families live together and maybe that's
what you guys still choose to do and all
of it I just want to be the friend that
doesn't know you to caution you Jonathan
that that that everything you're saying
is so Noble and good and I'm just
wondering is there another path that
those things can still happen that your
parents are still taken care of they
still see the grandkids all of those um
dreams and wants and desires are still
fulfilled without having to live under
the same roof as your
parents true so pivoting away from a
little bit of the noble side of it um
the what would be in it for um for my
wife and I would be um
that my parents and they're totally on
board with this we've been very
transparent with them but um my parents
would help us basically to afford more
house than we would on our own currently
have see and that but that's the part
that I would avoid at all costs because
do you want to be a like if something
were to happen like what Rachel said say
you get into this and you're like you
know what this is not as harmonious as
we once thought it was going to be now
you're on the hook for a home that you
can't afford on your own so there's part
of this that it's a little bit of a risk
there's a big risk there so I would say
if you were going to go ahead and do
this I wouldn't get into a home that you
could not afford on your own because and
I because then you're kind of chained to
this deal both of you you are and then
your parents are going to feel bad and
then you're going to feel bad and like
there's so much that could happen there
I did want to ask have you guys ever
lived with these parents before like
early on in marriage like or would this
be the first time you guys have all
lived under one
roof um I did briefly after college um
we actually got married in their current
house um but not not for a sustained
period of time now how
long
um so after college I lived back home
for a couple of months
and then um I mean we stay with them
anytime we visit but not more than a
week at time but not with your wife I'm
saying well with with my wife not after
college but with my wife for periods of
so John so part of your so your
motivation to do this is to be the noble
taking care of your parents and getting
a bigger house essentially that you guys
couldn't afford on your own but you get
you and your family get an awesome big
house okay right of economy the scale
with it brings down our living expenses
for both sides um but yeah that's that's
kind of bills and like like electricity
and
water uh like is that you're thinking
when you're food maintenance of two
separate
houses okay okay okay what the situation
you guys are in right now Jonathan the
house that you're in what what's is
there is there problems with that is
there size issues is there like is there
anything are you guys comfortable in
your current living situation long term
I don't see this house lasting us more
than a few more years so why
um the layout of it we've it's 2500
square feet that sounds like a lot more
than it feels like the house is um it's
not laid out very well okay and and how
much do you guys owe on that
house uh mortgage is 175 remaining for a
house that's worth about 410 410 okay uh
and how much you guys make a year uh 120
single income 120 okay you're making it
and then your parents their situation
what how much what what what's their
home worth they their home is worth
about 300,000 they have about 65,000
remaining on the mortgage awesome and
how much are they are they working
they're still both working and their
combined household incomes about 180
okay and do they have retirement like do
they have a nice retirement yes yeah
they're they're expecting their
retirement especially if they can keep
working a few more years years uh to be
somewhere around 80,000 a year not
drawing from Investments perfect and
they'll be having that house paid off
soon okay so Jonathan um how far away do
you guys live from each other now about
eight hours how much about eight hours
eight okay so it is long distance right
now so you guys want to be you want you
want to be close us moving to another
Midwestern metro area okay is it cheaper
than
Minneapolis Town comparable they're both
relatively low to comparable okay and
does your do your careers allow you to
move and find something in the same
field amount of money and all I need is
an airport and that would that would
work perfectly there okay and um they
they don't need your assistance right
now medically correct correct and when
when do you see that
happening
um that's a a situation we'll know more
in um probably six months okay is it
both of them or one of
them potentially both um what is it
what's going what's going on with them
can I ask so my my dad has some back
issues that uh
that um causes him pain he's still able
to fully functional yeah he might have
some surgical procedure to try and
address it that might have some risks
with it okay what about your mom
associated with it um she's got she's
got an early screening for potential
dementia I'm
sorry um so no no definitive diagnosis
there but would become an issue okay
yeah absolutely um okay I don't want to
sound heartless as I move into tactical
real quick we just we have 30 seconds
real fast Jonathan so here's what I
would do if I was your friend and me and
Winston were out with you Jonathan and
your wife over drinks and we're talking
about your situation I would say if you
guys want to move closer to family to be
with family do it go get your own house
they're about to have a paid for home
they're living their retirement dream go
close to them so that you guys can can
commute and do what you need to do there
if you if there's no urgency to move now
unless there's something coming there's
nothing definitive right now in their
medical history that that is necessary a
scary thing in y and that that can be
but I would not combine just to get a
bigger house Jonathan I wouldn't I would
I would Nei so that's what Jade and Sam
and Winston and Rachel would say if we
were all out to dinner with you Jonathan
I'm not doing it y so um I yeah I
appreciate the nobility though Jonathan
thanks for the call this is the ramsy
show
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I am at
Rachel Cruz hosting with Jade warshaw
and taking your calls if you guys have
not checked out Financial Peace
University this is something that is a
staple here at Ramsey Solutions um that
I I would really recommend it is our
nine lesson course on how to handle your
money from the basics to everything you
wish you had learned when it comes to
insurances and mortgage and budgeting
and paying off debt everything so you
know to take a quick class you know you
can you can watch the lessons you can uh
join a class actually and be in
community with other people while you're
doing this but uh we find that people
that are take FPU they are debt free and
two years or less and their financial
turnaround is just amazing so if you
want to just know more if you're new to
this show a lot we have a lot of new
people from podcast and YouTube and
you're like man I just need like a crash
course on getting my money in order what
do I do go to ramsy solutions.com FPU
and check that out because it really is
um it's a great investment we have that
tool in every dollar um premium which is
another it's like the best budgeting
tool on the planet you guys so I just we
were talking to some people that come
here and they sit in the lobby here at
Ramsey Solutions and they watch the show
live which is so fun and so we get to
talk to people during the breaks and
everything and uh I would say every
dollar is probably the one that gets
brought up of like oh my gosh you know
we we use every dollar we love it it's
helped us so much and so uh make sure
there's a free version just on the App
Store so check that out so we just have
some great resources here at Ramy want
to be able to help you uh when it comes
this to this financial Journey because
there's a lot of questions could be a
lot of confusion a lot of voices out
there and we want to be clear and
concise if you all I agree no every
dollar is the that's that's the business
right there and because it has the
guidance in there for you too so it's
like if you have questions it's in there
telling you hey you should probably do
this or if you're thinking I wonder if
this is enough savings it'll tell you
like yeah you need a little bit more
like it'll tell you all that stuff it's
wonderful yeah and we actually do some
webinars around every dollar so if you
go to Every doll.com bugeting Jade
you're doing some I'm doing some mine's
coming up 1010 oh perfect oh it's coming
up soon yeah okay so uh go to
everydollar.com bugeting you can sign up
for those webinars I'm doing one in
November and December I think George
campell's doing some as well so we are
um yep here to help you guys so make
sure to check out all those resources
because we want to help you along this
journey all right up next we have
Gregory and bxy hey hey Gregory welcome
to the
show Gregory are you there how are you
doing yes ma'am good how are
you I am doing great how are you we are
doing awesome how can we help
today um I have some questions on how to
get my Roth IRA started um I've heard a
lot about it and I just don't know
exactly where to go and and what to what
to put my money into yeah that's a great
question a great starting off point so
if it were me I would I mean there's
several brokerages that you could open
up a Roth IRA with and you could do that
portion on your own just open up the
account but when it comes to the
investing side of it I would work with a
professional I'd work with a smart
Vestor Pro and if you're on baby step 4
the goal is that you're investing 15% of
your income are you on baby step
4 uh I am yes man' awesome how much how
much do you make a year uh I make about
60 65 okay perfect perfect um yeah so I
mean yeah you'll be able to invest do
you have a 401k at your at your
workplace by chance I do um and I have
it maxed out to the match I also have
one with the my second job the reserves
and the Marine Corps I have it maxed out
to match to go well done Gregory that's
amazing yeah um so I'm trying to get to
that 15% with the Roth IRA that I wanted
to know how to get to it yeah that's
awesome thinking you'll have yeah a
little over you know probably Seven
Grand to be able to invest
uh that 15% and that's uh that's amazing
because you'll take yeah you'll do the
match first and that's exactly right
you're doing everything exactly right do
the match first and then go over to the
Roth and then for all of you listening
out there you know you go ahead and max
out your Roth and if you still have 15%
left if you still have percentages left
of your 15 go back to your 401k and
you're able to invest in that too um go
back to that but yeah the Roth IRA is
the next step for you Gregory and you
can Max it out at 6,000 you probably
won't Max it out right now um with your
income but all the extra remaining 15%
you have yes will go into that WTH and
um Jade said it but I would sit down
with the smart investor Pro if you go to
Ramsey solutions.com we have people all
all over the country who are investment
professionals and yeah you can actually
open up the account on your own uh but
we we would encourage you to do good
growth stock mutual funds that's right
inside of that Roth IRA uh to invest so
that your money is spread out and um
it's a great it's a great retirement
vehicle the Roth yeah tell them you want
tell them you want growth aggressive
growth growth in income and
international that's what you want 25%
of the money you give them into each of
those categories and they'll help you
pick the funds that are performing best
in those
areas okay yep awesome Gregory for the
call yeah well done thanks for your
service and um man that's it I'm like if
I applaud you Gregory like that's
exactly it you get through to baby step
four take that 15% and divide it 401K
Roth IR and and you do that over time
and how quickly compound interest is
your friend and and stuff with the WTH
You guys like it grows taxfree and it's
and it's huge it does kind of hurt
sometimes because you pay with after tax
dollars right right right so it does
feel a little bit like oh man I got to
take it out of like when it hits your
account you're like and then it comes
out of that like you're like that's a
lot you feel it you feel it but you
rather feel it now then when you're 60
you know so all day all day long so
great all right up next we have uh Rudy
in Los Angeles hey Rudy welcome to the
show hey guys thank you for having me
absolutely how can we help um so my
question is I am currently upside down
on my carnal hey Rudy are you able to
are you able to speak directly into your
phone you're cutting out just a little
bit I want to make sure we can hear you
yes you guys better now yes wonderful
thanks so I'm currently upside down on
my car loan my car loans for
37,000 um I made some calls let's see um
how much I can get for it and the guy
from auction said I can possibly get 31
maybe 32 for it um that is my means of
transportation at the moment why are you
auctioning
it as opposed to so I and put it the VIN
uh the mileage and the details of the
vehicle and based on the market value of
the vehicle that's approximately how
much they're offering um for the current
condition that it's in did you look at
like Kelly Blue
Book uh actually tried that the only
thing is
um quick backstory uh I got the car last
year um within 6 months that I purchased
the vehicle or I got the Lo for the
vehicle it got stolen so on yeah so on
the title it comes as as it's branded
now and so when I put it into Kelly Blue
Book since the car has a branded title
um they don't they don't want to give me
uh an offer you said it has a bad title
but you got the car back and it was your
car to begin with yes correct who's
telling you
this um I in put it on KY blue books and
other like carvana and uh these other
places and they didn't want to offer me
uh any anything for it they offered me
literally like a dollar for it um
because it it had a it said branded
title vehicle and because of that they
didn't want to give me an offer for it
branded
title yes so what about personal
sale personal yeah that's what I've been
trying to look into um do you hold the
title on this car like who it's
uh my mom's a call center with me um so
it's under both of our names
okay
interesting okay so are you are you
wondering if you should sell the car or
you're you're wanting to sell it
obviously yes but uh I guess my question
is how do it go about it do I wait until
I can uh get a vehicle cash so I don't
feel like I without a vehicle I just
sell it and then work on getting yeah
you could that money to get the vehicle
yeah because you'll have to take out a
loan of the difference which will be
about five grand so what you could do is
just take out a loan for 10 grand and
have
$5,000 to buy a car um because I would
rather have a $10,000 loan than a
$37,000 loan and so um so yeah so if I
were you you could take out but um
always my caution when you do that is
it's like oh well we could take out you
know 12,000 we could take out 13 you
could start going deeper and deeper in
debt and so being very disciplined in it
and again you're going to be buying a
car a crappy car right that's uh that's
going to get you through but yeah I
would do that Rudy um I think that's a
really smart a smart decision and I know
uh this this whole thing's probably new
and you're like oh my gosh how do we how
do we go about it but uh I think that's
wise take out a small loan uh get a car
and gosh get that $377,000
away I'd rather have 10 than 37 so great
job Rudy Jade great hour thanks to all
the guys in the booth and thank you
America for listening this is the ramsy
[Music]
show hey what's up guys it's Jade look
if you like what you heard in this
episode and want to know more about
getting started on the ramsy baby steps
go to ramsy solutions.com and click the
get started button we'll help you figure
out the best next step for you based on
your specific situation that's ramseys
solutions.com and click get
[Music]
started live from the headquarters of
Ramsey Solutions it's the ramsy show
where we help people build wealth do
work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships I am Rachel Cruz
hosting this hour with fellow Ramsey
personality and great friend Jade
warshaw and we are taking your calls
America free call anywhere in the
country at
88255 225 so give us a call all right up
next we have Alexandra on the line hey
Alexandra welcome to the show hi hi
Rachel and Jade how are you we are doing
great doing great how can we help
okay so I'm in a bit of a situation here
um
so we we purchased a well okay so we
closed on our house um on the 24th of
August oh congratulations and thank you
um I don't know how we got it but we
went in with all we had um kind of
desperate just wanting to get out of a
$2,100 rent and yep and then we're at a
$1,400 mortgage now um firsttime home
buyers we've been together since sixth
grade um um we're 37 years old we have
two um kindergartens that just started
the twin boys started year so um this is
our situation we closed we moved so
we're uh I think about 2 hours north um
from his previous job and I say previous
because two weeks after we closed he
lost his job
no yeah no fault of his own it was just
you know a car that was given to him so
that he can drive to work he was doing
that you know obviously every day um and
so now he didn't have a transportation
to get there because I need the car to
bring the kids to work to to school
because they just started school this
year um so he's he's unemployed right
now um this is my husband but I'm I'm
I'm so scared because um and I'm hoping
that he can get into something right
very soon um we were able to make so we
Clos in August our first um mortgage
payment was on the 1 we were able to
make that so we sent it out that's done
it's $1,400
right okay and so now we're having to
pay again you know on the first um we
only have like $1,600 in
savings um the big thing is if he so
we're we're hoping he can get into this
new job next week um so it's going to be
a little bit of a a pay cut um so it'll
be at 62 a year he was earning more
closer to 80 a year but now we're out in
the country farm life this is what we
wanted this is what we get he's going to
get paid less sure um so he's down at
62 can you make can you pay all the
bills with him at 62 I think we can
because if we were already doing it then
and and and yeah he was making more but
we were spending much more and then now
I'm like uhuh when I'm doing that yeah
um you know so we can I know we can um
but this is the thing let me get to it
quick um the RV we have a RV that is 30k
a note of 30k on it and the payment is
400 bucks a month um I don't know what
to do to it with with it because we're
just just parked in our land here and
and it's it's a 2017 we got it
desperately in uh 2021 because we were
needing to get out an apartment that we
were living in and the house that we had
you know we were trying to get into at
that time it the sale didn't go through
so so that I won't have to release you
know another contract we just went to a
campground and so we got the we got the
RV and then we just kept um house
searching we found the house and then so
here we still have it what can you what
can you sell it for yeah I don't know to
be honest um I'm sure it's going to be
less than what we owe yeah yeah you'll
take a hit on it but you're just trying
to stop the payments and stop the
depreciation from taking you guys we
don't have any late payments Sunday we
were able to make that last month but
this is the month right now coming up
this one in November is the one that's
going to hit us it's going to it's I
don't know how we're going to do it yeah
um when will you know if your husband
has the
job um he will find on Monday and and I
think and I want to go with 90% they're
going to take him on okay good yeah and
so it's going to be a pay cut you know
um yeah so so I want you the first thing
I want you doing um is you've got a lot
going on and I can tell by the way
you're telling the situ it's like you're
just like in this and you're just keep
keeping going um and I want to kind of
clear your head a little bit tonight
when you get off the phone you guys sit
down run run the numbers use every doll
open up every dollar budget if you don't
have it Austin will get it to you and I
want you to run the numbers for your
paycheck and his paycheck at the 62,000
all right then I want you to run the
numbers just in case he doesn't get this
job and go what do we need coming in the
house to make sure we're able to fill
because once you have those numbers in
your head uh Alexandri you're going to
feel so much better because at least
you'll know what the real numbers are
what the anecdote is and then you'll be
able to make a game plan going forward
what I really want to hone in on and I
think Rachel will do a good job with
this too is I want you guys there's a
lot of desperate moves going on
everything is oh we got desperate and we
had to do this and then we got desperate
and we had to do this and we got
desperate and the chain here the the
pattern that's happened is when you guys
get desperate you do you make bad
choices and I want that that's got to
stop today so what that looks like is in
in the here and now making a plan for
the here and now but not only that but
going forward I want you guys to be on a
plan with your money so you know what
your goals are you know what's going you
know what's coming down the pike and
you're in control and you're happening
to your life instead of everything
around you just happening to you guys
and you're reacting and you know you're
on the balls of your feet all the time
um that's got to change and I think that
a plan for your money is going to help
you have you ever heard of Financial
Peace
University um so no um just recently I
started listening to you guys I to be
honest I grew up I want to say in the
ghetto to be honest I never had money in
my life my both my mom and dad just
worked just to yeah take care of five of
us you know so um you know I just grew
up you know working and paycheck to
paycheck you know rent rent rent Rent
All my life until we were finally able
to get this and it was through an FHA
that's why I say we
lucky to get it but you know here we are
we're so happy we have a nice little
house sure sure but but also you're so
happy but you're also very stressed okay
so what we want you to see is and Jade's
exactly right being proactive with your
money versus reactive and you just said
it and I think the way we grow up with
money is a huge part of our story and
that's what was modeled for you um but
now the beautiful thing is now you get
to change that so Alexandra stay on the
line Austin's going to pick up and we're
going to give you every dollar premium
which is our budgeting app that we'll
we'll attach to your checking account it
will and you guys will be able to bring
in transactions you'll be able in real
time to be budgeting your expenses what
Jade was saying and we're going to give
you Financial Peace University which is
our nine lesson course and you and your
husband you guys need to learn how this
stuff works and Alexandra I'm going to
warn you it's going to feel
uncomfortable you said you're new to all
of this and when you you have to get to
this point and you're there I feel it
and you're in your voice and why you
called is you're not happy with your
current situation what you guys have
done that led you up to this point yes
he lost his job unbeknownst to him I get
it stuff has happened you are not happy
with where you are which means you have
to change what you've been doing and
change is hard Alexandra it's hard and
so you're going to be doing some painful
things that are going to feel
uncomfortable because they're new but
they're the right things to be doing we
are the best in the business at getting
people in control of their money so
listen to the plan follow the plan Don't
Stray From it and so looking at your
numbers getting facts on paper is going
to give you some breathing room you're
probably going to be selling the RV you
guys may have to take a second job in
order to to float the bills for for the
next month which is okay hopefully he
gets his job and you guys are on track
but you guys got to get your craft
together because craft together because
you're going to end up in the same place
again but we believe you guys can do it
you can you can you got to make the
[Music]
change
our question of the day comes from
neighborly and it's your hub for Home
Services neighborly has top quality
providers like Precision Door Service
Junk King and more more to help you take
care of projects before the weather gets
cold so find the local help that you
need by downloading the neighborly app
today all right all right today's
question comes from weson Rhode Island
he says I attended University of Phoenix
back in September 2014 and I have around
10,000 in federal student loans I
recently received an email from the FTC
saying that because University of
Phoenix committed fraud and used
unethical tactics to get student loans
to get students to en en roll federal
student loans are going to be forgiven
for anyone who enrolled between 2012 and
2014 I was very happy to receive this
news however when it comes to federal
government forgiving student loans I
don't have faith that it'll happen
should I have very for good reason
should I pause my payments and let
nature take its course or continue
making payments um I you know this is a
really good question and I'll be honest
there's been a lot of conversation and
narrative around student loan
forgiveness is it good is it bad should
it happen should it not happen um in
cases where there's been true fraud
fraud like yeah this is by the
government they ensure this so no it
will be paid yeah it'll be paid and you
don't have to feel bad about that's the
kind of forgiveness that I'm like yes
please green button you need to get your
money back um and I think it will be
paid now he says should I pause my
payments and let nature take its course
or continue paying um you know because
of the way student loans are set up
right now what I might do is I might put
the money in account like in an account
and kind of like set it aside and then
when the when the actual forgiveness
comes through I'll feel good about like
okay I can let that money go um what
would you do I mean that's what I would
do yeah I would contact because I mean
most of these places have um contacts
especially if it's a specific year like
this it sounds very specific yeah so I
would get in touch with somebody uh to
be able to say hey what's the timeline
what's going on and kind of see where
they're at because I mean you definitely
don't want to get in a situation where
you're getting behind on payments and
for some reason this doesn't go through
right um but I would kind of get a feel
because again this is this is legal
fraud so in this case uh the government
does ensure that I mean and this happens
a lot and and sometimes that hits the
headlines where they're like so and so
right now it's Biden Biden
Administration forgives x amount of
student loans you know this happened
with Trump too but I'm like those that
they were forgiving were actual fraud
cases like the sitution very specific
very narrow and they have to by federal
law yeah you know I mean that that that
is that they're they're living out what
the law says so it's not like these you
know it's a hero kind of thing yeah
Phoenix they screwed you or whatever you
know the way they did it like it's it's
fraudulent so what I wouldn't want is
for him to stop paying something
accumulate above and beyond and them say
well like that doesn't count I don't I
don't think they would but I would
definitely do what you said get clarity
get clarity get something in writing
that you know um but I think that these
kind of situations they do end up
clearing up which is awesome it will pay
you yep for sure uh well dang Wes guess
that's great yeah ding ding I guess but
at the same time it's like yeah my
school doesn't exist it was fake does
University does is it gone it's gone it
is gone like the IT Tech those Jokers
are out man yeah can you imagine can you
imagine I'd be so pissed that would be
so hard that you have a degree and
you're like listen I don't know although
in my case I think I'd like the money
back I think I'd rather have the money
back and be like oh your school doesn't
exist I think I have the money
absolutely give me the cash give me the
cashy all right up we have Amanda in
Tyler Texas hey Amanda welcome to the
show hi thank you for having me
absolutely how can we
help so my question is I have about 30
actually I looked at it I've got about
$35,000 in credit card debt um I'm going
through a divorce and so the beginning
of the divorce I had zero thank you um
at the beginning of the divorce I had um
you know zero debt I had we had $40,000
in savings cars paid off basically you
know doing everything that we should be
doing um you know according to Dave
rams's um teachings and uh now I've got
all this debt but I only get
$2,700 a month and I've gotten to the
point where the attorney fees keep
coming and I can't keep up with it and
so I have haven't made my payment on my
three credit cards for two months
and my question is do I just let it go
because I need to be saving money for
more attorney fees or do I try to find
some like I keep getting emails I mean
um letters for debt consolidation do I
try something like that or do I just let
my credit
score you know continue to think yeah
are you are you working
Amanda I don't I'm a I'm a homeschool
mom and at the time at right now I can't
move and I can't change the kids
schooling and so I tried picking up some
side
jobs um but then I ended up getting
needing to be hospitalized for a short
amount of time and um and so I have
those bills that I um submitted for
claims because since I'm still married I
still have medical insurance and um he's
refusing to sign the necessary paperwork
so now I have the medical facilities
calling me saying hey you owe us $40,000
cuz your claim was denied so I'm just
drowning um and knowing that once the
divorce is over with I probably won't
even be able to rent something because
my credit score is going to be so
horrible it started off as great and now
it's down like in the six low
600 okay well the credit score for right
now would not be my concern um yeah the
40,000 that the medical I mean if you're
still legally married I mean I would
have your lawyer on that that that that
feels that feels off to me the fact that
he's not uh you know accepting your
claim because you technically still do
have insurance but I mean I want to know
you know just just to look out for you
um what what are you planning on doing
when this is all final because you will
need health insurance you will need a
job and income coming in because I don't
know if you can live you can't live off
$2,700 a month with the kids especially
no yeah um so my plan was to go back to
school I was going to school to be a
court reporter and so I was planning on
finishing you know doing that online
while I just worked you know I don't
have any experience so you know I'd have
to do things like pet sitting and uh
waiting tables it's going to be a rough
few years yeah but without an education
I really can't take care for kids even
with um child support yeah it's just can
I I'm going to push you just a little
bit on that one um because we do I mean
the the the world has shifted to a to a
degree that that college degrees it
doesn't matter nearly the way it used to
the way it used to so I even wonder
Amanda for you like finding a great you
know even a receptionist job at a
dentist office like a dentist office
finding finding something that gives you
the hours you need gives you the
benefits that you need cuz you're going
to want the whole package instead of
piecing together all of these side
hustles um so I think you have more to
offer uh than you think and I understand
it's very int it would be very
intimidating going into the workforce
where you don't have experience yeah you
you said you've been you know a mom
you've been homeschooling kids but even
the skill set that you had that what
you've just done can be very impressive
to people that need help and in Tyler
Texas there's probably a lot of small
businesses that need admin work and all
that so I would give yourself way more
credit Amanda not that waiting tables
and dog sitting is is bad it's not but
you can earn more money but you can do
more and you will want to do more and
have more you know available when it
comes to benefits and everything just to
take care of you you and the kids and so
um I would I would push you on that
first and foremost that when that when
that comes and um and I would be looking
for something as soon as possible
because is the $35,000 in credit card
debt is that just living expenses that
you've had to rack up because you don't
have enough money to pay the
bills no um it's actually mostly
attorney fees and medical because I've
been covering all of all of the medical
bills okay um for myself and and our
children and so so is the is the 35 so
you mentioned 35k in credit cards and
40,000 in medical is that kind of
synonymous then if you've been paying it
on the credit
cards no the 40,000 is just it's new
it's as of last month um that came in
addition to it um yeah and the other
issue is that now I've kind of ran the
divorce have been going on for a year
and so it could be going on even longer
um yep okay so um so me yeah keeping up
with those attorney fees it may cause
some of that debt to continue to
increase but I think looking for a job
and supplemental income is going to be
your next bet just to get you on solid
foundation and taking care of yourself
too Amanda I hate we we have a hard
clock out here in a second but hang on
the line Austin's going to pick up and
I'm going to give you John's new book uh
building a non-anxious life because
taking care of you Amanda overall is
going to be really important in this
season thanks for
[Music]
calling
welcome back to the Ramsey show we are
taking your calls America at
5225 up next we have Tracy in Phoenix
hey Tracy welcome to the
show Hello thank you so much for taking
my call absolutely thanks for calling in
how can we
help yeah this really is going to take a
lot of stress off of me um so I have a
situation where I just moved from
Georgia and I have a home there that's
paid off um it's probably worth we
haven't appraised it yet but it's
probably worth between 280 and 300,000
okay um I moved to Phoenix and I live in
an apartment um and I'm currently um you
know just trying to get my credit score
up and I'm actually working with the
lender so I can purchase a home here um
now I have the down payment um the 20%
to buy a home here and me selling my
house in Georgia has nothing to do with
me purchasing here oh wow and so my
question is yeah so my question is um
should I sell the home in Georgia and
use some of that um money to make the
payment lower and to bring it you know
the house down in Phenix a little bit
lower and then possibly buy a second
home here as a rental and put the other
half maybe on that home or should I
leave that house in Georgia as a rental
property sell it yes it I would say
unanimous yep unanimous sell it and I
would put everything of that home Tracy
um that 300 to the home in Phoenix I
would not look at a second property
until that house is completely paid off
do you have other
debt um I do that's the thing I I just
recently paid off a lot of credit cards
but I do have about
158,000 and
stop okay I feel like you're jumping the
gun a little bit yeah we may have a plan
for you
Tracy we have we have no other debt it's
me and my husband combined we make about
195k that's great good for you guys can
I tell you my plan can I tell you the
Jade plan plan this is what I would do I
would sell the No No matter what you do
you're selling the home in Georgia
that's we got to get rid of you don't
live there anymore and so it's just
going to be can I ask one one number
question to help your argument hey how
much how much is the 20% down how much
cash do you have saved in the 20% cuz
we're add that to all
this the 20% well I have about 25 which
actually it's really not the 20% it's
the 5% okay oh that's fine how much is
it 25,000 I could yeah it's about 25 but
I could access it do my husband's 401K
no no no no we don't do that how much
cash Tracy do you have saved
25,000 25 yeah okay perfect okay you and
now I do have another question so you've
got 25,000 saved is that the only
non-retirement money you have lying
around or do you have other
non-retirement
savings I have no other non-retirement
money okay this is what Jade would do I
would like if Jade and Sam woke up in
your shoes tomorrow I'd be like okay Sam
I think we should sell the house in
Georgia pocket you know take home
280,000 and then with that money I would
knock out the student loans and then I
would put the rest with the 25,000 that
you have saved towards a down payment
now my next question is that I want to
do that but now let me go back because
you need savings you need three to six
months of savings before you buy a house
you'll she'll end up with about 155 yeah
$155,000 so I would put sum in savings
three to six months of expenses and how
much would that be if you were to rough
that out
Tracy um monthly expenses yeah like
basic basic budgeting
expenses let's just say 4K with the
kidss tuition per
month yeah okay so around 25,000 for six
months okay so we got we got
$143,000 to put towards a house and look
at that and you're debt free with
savings wow look at that come on Tracy
are you doing a happy dance that's
great I am doing the happy dance see
some people are saying you should never
sell a house that's paid off number they
don't know what they're talking
about yeah and it was your primary home
Tracy if that was your primary home and
you're still living in Georgia that's
one thing but you're being a
long-distant landlord you have an asset
which is amazing but you also have
liability which is your debt and so
you're able to clean all that up still
get a great house in Phoenix with an
emergency fund in place like you're
going to be M good to go um and you're
going to have a lot more peace than
trying to finagle all of this stuff so
you're starting on really really solid
ground Tracy I mean like you're this is
it's amazing what kind of the houses
that you're looking at in Phoenix
considering you have
$143,000 left to to what how much are
the houses you're looking
at like
538 high
30s No 5 oh five 538 okay and so when
you do go to buy a home let's go over
these parameters because we want to make
sure that it's it works out for you the
way we would teach and the way that you
know I've always bought my homes is
15year fixed mortgage where the payment
is no more than 25% of your take-home
pay
that's what we're looking for so if you
can do that with the down payment which
you shouldn't have any trouble um but
that's what you're shooting for but the
15-year fixed rate is really where
that's the one where people are like n
can't I just do the 30 it's like the
goal here is to pay things off and to
get that ultimate freedom of debt
Freedom so that's why we'd say 15E fixed
and you might get a better interest rate
as well um by going that route but is
that what you're planning to
do yeah um the interest rates right now
are like 8% aren't they High I don't
know if I yes they're higher most
definitely for sure for sure but the 15
year you'll get a better rate but Jade
is saying versus the 30 so okay yeah so
Tracy I mean that's yeah that's exactly
the the road we would take and it just
sets you up that and you guys make great
money you know you'll have about 350
left on the mortgage to be paying off
but you're making 200 so you guys have
this house paid off uh you know on
average we find people pay off their
house in seven years s to 10 years and
it's it's amazing and you guys are going
to be just Trucking along with not de no
debt and just yeah it's gonna be amazing
so glad you called in Tracy glad you
called in all right we got Payton up
next in Lexington Kentucky hey pton
welcome to the show hi Rachel hi Jade
how are you we're doing great how can we
help so I'm on baby step two I have paid
off
$30,000 nice car left I'm sorry you have
a what thousand car left left 30,000 we
were cheering Payton sorry we missed we
missed the number no thank you um I have
an $88,000 settlement coming in within
the next four to six weeks and that will
put me a right side up on the car
because it's worth about
$23,000 okay and I was wondering I could
pay it off by May or I could sell it and
be debt free as soon as I get the
settlement um what would your decision
be because I know Dave always says if
you can pay it off within two years and
you love the car you can keep it fight
for it yeah um how much are you how much
do you make a year uh 108,000 oh yeah
yeah I would I would keep it you're fine
I think the numbers are fine yeah I
think you can pay it off even sooner
honestly pton yeah I mean you'll have
the 8K in cash to dump at it that's
great cuz did yeah that's what I
do okay I don't know if it' change
anything I have a old beater jeep that
is worth maybe $1,000 doll but take me
three to $4,000 to get it daily
drivable um would you still just uh keep
the car and just paid off by May or
sooner I think that part's up to you at
that point if
I that I I you honestly I think that's
totally up to you it depends like
obviously the I'm guessing the Jeep is
not as in as good a shape as a $30,000
car but it really just depends on the
picture of your life that you want going
forward either either either way is fine
all right yeah yeah you're gonna get it
paid off the the numbers aren't so
lopsided that we're like oh my gosh get
this car out of here pton you know
because you're a yeah you're able to pay
it off within six months which is
amazing uh but if you're not attached to
the car and Payton we get a lot of
people on this show and they're like get
me out as soon as possible I'll throw
two grand at this Jeep get it fixed up
and I'm great driving it around and I'm
happy and it's awesome if that's what
you want to do do that and be out of Deb
yeah you know in four weeks after you
fix the Jeep you can do that but also
that this car payment or this car loan
is not absolutely going to kill you you
you make great money you're going to be
able to pay it off and you'll be
completely debt free after that uh which
is just well on your way so yep I'm I'm
with Jade that one that one's in your
court Payton but uh thanks for the call
appreciate it this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
our scripture of the day comes from
Ecclesiastes
712 the protection of wisdom is like the
protection of money and the advantage of
knowledge is that wisdom preserves the
life of him who has
it have a tongue twister there Jade yeah
to repeat I'm going to have to marinate
on that one and Frank said people can
tell you to keep your mouth shut but
that doesn't stop you from having your
own opinion okay I like that great so
good all right up next we have uh Paige
in North Dakota hey Paige welcome to the
show hello uh my question is or I guess
uh my husband does doesn't want to try
and budget every time I bring it up it's
this big fight about who spends most
money on the most worthless things and I
don't know how
to handle that it's beyond that it's the
tip for Tat game you did this well I did
that when you do this so how are when
when these conversations come up let's
kind of retro back a little bit when
these conversations have come up have
they come up in the heat of the moment
or has it been like hey honey or hey boo
whatever you call your spouse I want to
sit down and talk here's what I'd like
to talk about you know um is it that
sort of thing or is it just like this is
happening out of the heat of a moment of
somebody opening up a bill for
something I I wouldn't say it's nor like
the key to the moment but it's always
like when we go paycheck to paycheck
week after week you always scraping the
barrel and then I'm like hey can we try
this and then he like gets super mad
about it and then it's just paycheck to
paycheck it's the same thing you just
want to break that cycle um yeah part of
it I think I think part of it how you
approach it I think that if instead of
uh attacking the conversation as we need
to stop doing this you know we're just
living paycheck to paycheck you know
we've got to start getting on a budget I
think if you kind of approach it in the
way of um I'm really I'm really worried
and I'm really scared and I've just been
noticing like my anxiety is going nuts
and I think it's because we're
overspending I think it's because we are
not on the same page and I'd really like
to be on the same page what does that
look like to you like I'd kind of throw
the ball on their CT of like what do you
think that looks like and that way it's
not you saying not necessarily coming in
saying this is what we need to be doing
but just opening up that conversation
have you tried
that I have tried that and I've
suggested few different things like hey
we put Wolford paychecks into the joint
account for bills and such you can put x
amount I use like $300 for an example
into your own personal account to spend
it on what you want you know gas station
whatever and then once you go past that
you can't dip into the
uh yeah okay so page already can I say
this already it's becoming a page is
telling what's your husband's name or if
you don't want to say well Bob Bob we'll
come
Bob okay
okay uh it's already you almost in a
maternal role of okay we're going to put
your money here and you can't do this
and this this this it it is still this
hierarchy of you being the kind of
authority in a sense and so the goal
would be just to paint you a picture is
that you are both a team you both are
equal in this he has as much say in this
as you do you have as much say as he
does and it's you guys together saying
oh yeah this and this and this and this
versus one telling one what to do if
that makes sense and so um yeah no that
makes sense yeah and I would say this
too with an aster there's naturally
always going to be more of the nerd and
there's naturally always going to be the
free spirit so like Winston forever will
love Excel and love the budget and love
painting out what investments of this
this this more than me which is funny
because this is my job and this is like
what I do every day but he actually is
more of the numbers and thrives on that
and more of the saver than I am so he
won't change who I am but the way we
approach our money together can still be
as a team so always know that you still
will have your own personalities he may
never just love the budget like Paige
does and that's okay but as long as
you're both in it together that's going
to be the goal so I would want to know
do do you do you know his hesitation
what what it is that he kind of pushes
back against and why or why he pushes
back against us
I think he likes to kind of be in
control a little bit um I know he's
always brought back that before we even
got together I had no problem you know
with my money but so he's trying to kind
of make it you're the blame kids are the
blame but live or like our lives have
changed since we met you know sure we
live in a different place and things are
more expensive and to kids to do through
daycare and yep so I would ask then back
just to keep the conversation going I
think Jade's Point's really good is like
I want to hear from him and so like okay
so you're saying that before all of this
you were you know you you didn't have
money problems which to a degree duh
because you didn't have all these
expenses right that's what we're all
thinking but also what what were what
did you have in place that worked really
well because he may have his own way of
doing stuff that you know you don't see
uh that maybe you actually could
Implement and so I think again it's
going back to to this like it's this
team mentality which I know is so easier
said than done page cuz we're about to
get off the air here in 5 minutes and
and go home and I know you're the one
that's having to have these
conversations but as much as you guys
can sit down and say gosh I feel like
this is pinning us against each other
and we can't be against each other like
we are in this together and we both want
to win like like no one wants to choose
to have a stressful anxious life and
marriage and so and no one's trying to
say whose fault it is like if you and
Bob can both agree this the problem is
it's us it's us like we're we're
paycheck to paycheck both of us don't
like that both of us would love to get
to a point where we've got savings and
you know we we're out of debt like if
you guys can surround that and like lock
arms around that and that's where you're
going to move forward yeah and sometimes
Paige especially with guys that's kind
of a stereotype so it may not be true
for him but I have found like when you
can put numbers and actual facts instead
of just ideas and theories of cutting
back and all this when you actually see
numbers down sometimes it helps because
you can actually blame the numbers
instead of blaming each other and so I
would just say hey one night like after
dinner can we please will you and just
ask them can you will you just give me
an hour and I want to pull out the bills
and I just want to look and like what if
I just want to and help me do it right
bring him in that you're Paige isn't
bringing everything and Paige isn't
telling what the numbers are together
we're having a conversation so will you
just sit down because I want to know
like okay are you spinning on gas and
you guys just make this puzzle and lay
out the numbers and kind of just do a
mock budget together again try I don't
want it to be conflict filled or tension
filled this is just bringing numbers to
the table uh and let that be a starting
point because I think sometimes in our
heads things can be magnified in our
heads things can be isolating there's so
much that if we just keep up in our head
and in our mind it just can go sideways
and when things are down and you're
looking at actual facts and looking at
actual
numbers sometimes not always but
sometimes that kind of like diffuses the
tension um because you see that and then
from there you know look at the Tactical
and then also it's if it's going well
that night or maybe it's another night
dream and just say hey what would it
look like in five years what does our
life look like how old are our kids what
grade are they going to be in where do
we want to be like just start to like
have this vision of where you guys want
to be as a family and there's something
about being proactive in that that is so
inspired ing than just living life
paycheck to paycheck month to month and
you look up and it's been 5 years and
you don't know where you know you don't
know where you're going and so having
that I think is really key too Paige but
just know you're not alone in this this
is one of the biggest problems we hear
from people is that one spouse is on
board and wants to do this and another
isn't so you're not alone in it and also
we've heard so many couples on our debt
free stage say gosh I wasn't on board I
thought y'all were crazy and and then
finally we all I got on board and
together we did this so even couples who
win
start out where you guys are so have
hope page that this can change it it
really can but I think it's really the
way you approach don't be the mom
definitely don't be the mom have a
humble Spirit about it um but bring you
know this conversation it's a
conversation to be had it's not pointing
fingers and and blame even this picture
of put the numbers out in front of you
and like lock arms and like it's us
against you numbers like you know what I
mean it's not us against each other so
it's good uh it's powerful page that's a
it's a big part of winning is you and
your spouse and just for the sake of
your marriage not just your money for
the sake of your marriage I pray that um
that this brings you guys together so
thanks for the call Jade thanks for a
great show today it was good always fun
always fun thanks to the guys in the
boots make it happen thanks to the
audience that came out today to
Nashville to watch the show live we
appreciate you guys and we appreciate
you America for listening this is the
ramsy
show hey it's Rachel Cruz if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the ramsy baby steps go to ramsy
solutions.com and click the get started
button we'll help you figure out the
best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's ramsy
solutions.com and click get
started